at Carnegie Mellon University innovation
is part of our DNA we are defined by our
creative spark tireless work ethic and
commitment to problem solving we make a
relevant impact on the lives of everyday
people a world leader in technology and
robotics we are creating smarter homes
for families homes that can alert us to
dangers and better serve us as we age
the vision we have at the center is to
develop technology to help people live
independently and that in itself might
have a more profound effect on their
quality of life because they feel better
about themselves and what they can do we
develop new health tools to diagnose
diseases like cancer personalized
treatments and predict the side effects
of medications before billions of
dollars are spent what we need to be
able to do is to build models that will
enable us to predict how will a
particular combination of tumor cells
and a particular combination of tumor
phenotypes respond to different
combinations or drugs we are unlocking
the secrets of the human mind to
discover new therapies for disorders
like autism what we're doing is trying
to tie the biology the brain a neural
activity to the ideas that we're
thinking about it's not just a hot spot
it's a hot spot of information
processing and through our machine
learning methods we've been able to
interpret what that hot spot of
information is we invent solutions
across disciplines this is the place
where engineers computer scientists
policymakers economists and designers
work together for a more sustainable
world
we are a leader in areas like green
chemistry and sustainable design you
take these molecules that are not don't
go away easily in nature that lasting
water forever essentially on and Tamil
peroxide or hammer them to oblivion in
minutes Carnegie Mellon is developing
new technologies to make solar and other
alternative energies practical and more
affordable so we can make plastics that
conduct electricity or absorb light from
the Sun and turn the light into
electricity we're discovering new ways
to make our air and water cleaner and
make burning fossil fuels less harmful
to our planet hopefully the work we're
now doing will point the way over the
next decade or two both in terms of
technology but also in terms of
regulatory strategy
we don't just imagine the future we
create from the start our strengths and
research and the arts have grown
together yielding innovations that
affect everything from how we
communicate to the design of the places
where we live and work by combining our
strengths in the arts with technology we
are creating the art forms of the future
like art that is aware of you there's
something about the way people move
through space this is absolutely unique
to them and when you can capture that
have a computer which can understand
that they learn something about
themselves that they may not have even
seen we get out of the ivory tower and
into the world you get pan and all of
the global connections project is
fundamentally about connecting people to
each other and to the environment in
other words to our world so if people
are humanizing each other if those
conversations happening between people
who would never talk to each other then
we're succeeding Carnegie Mellon has
always responded to the needs of the
real world where economic challenges are
global international banks and financial
organizations seek the counsel of our
monetary policy experts the public is it
is developing a taste for quality
thinkers so that I think we have an
opportunity at Carnegie Mellon in
particular to leverage our understanding
of the world we prepare future engineers
to manage innovation in multinational
environment Carnegie Mellon is a world
leader in social and decision sciences
exploring how psychological and economic
factors shape decision-making the work I
do is is a combinational economics
information security and psychology
white people reveal personal data or
they don't we capitalize on the
synergies between information systems
and public policy and deal with new
challenges like credit card debt in
global cyber threat
we fearlessly reinvent our areas of
excellence we will be at the forefront
of next-generation computing and the
communication technologies that will
drive our interconnected world we've
expanded the real world into this
virtual world of cyberspace and with
that comes a new type of citizenship
that's required we need to interact in
this virtual world with the same level
of social responsibility each day
internet users come into contact with
ideas that originated at Carnegie Mellon
so you've seen the squiggly characters
that you have to type so we invented
those here at Carnegie Mellon that thing
is called a CAPTCHA and so what we're
doing now is we're getting people while
they're typing those squiggly characters
on the internet to help us digitize
books we build on our existing
technology expertise to move into new
areas revolutionising education seeking
to understand the origins of the
universe and transforming science itself
it's really not just about physics but
physics and computer science and
statistics and using computers to help
understand the universe and Carnegie
Mellon like no other university excels
in the interdisciplinary
at carnegie-mellon we imagine the
impossible we are entrepreneurial
educators virtual storytellers eco
visionaries computational biologists
interactive artists and behavioral
economists we are architects of change
we invite you to support our new ideas
and help create a better future together
we can inspire innovation